death to america went the cry
as protesters attacked the u.s embassy
in baghdad
fire and fury of an iraqi kind
[Applause]
met by tear gas and orders to disperse
some broke inside the rest
held stones and insults from outside the
compound walls
they're angry at u.s airstrikes against
an iranian-backed militia in iraq
accused of targeting u.s forces
the yellow and green flag of the khatib
hezbollah militia
evidence of whose side thereon
it is flagrant aggression it is
aggression on iraq's sovereignty
it is a violation of all norms and
values this aggression
won't pass unpunished this man's the
leader of another militia group with
ties to iran
his fighters opposed british forces when
they were based in southern iraq
and he's no fan of america
[Music]
this embassy is the place of supporting
the american joker
this place is where all operations of
sabotage have been run
this place is where the sovereignty of
the country is violated
actually this place is supposed to be
protected u.s property
president donald trump accused iran of
orchestrating the attack against it
they will be held fully responsible he
said in addition
we expect iraq to use its forces to
protect the embassy
so notified sunday's airstrikes were
meant to notify iran
to stop attacking u.s troops with its
iraqi proxies
this funeral procession of some of the
fighters killed in the attack
a sign that this message was delivered
but the american action
is seen here as a violation of iraqi
sovereignty
by a former invader there is huge
animosity
towards the us uh in in iraq not in all
of iraq
all the time but from very large
sections of the population
and we understand why that is and it's
going to be very hard to diminish it
quickly
rage at the embassy shows no sign of
fading
but the united states remains determined
to stand its ground
debra haynes sky news